wir wollen jetzt einmal durch
deutschland scheiden schauen wie die sie
reden also dort aufgestellt sind als
allererstes sind wir in dresden jürgen
helfricht ist für uns dort jürgen in
dresden gibt es ja besonders moderne
serien aufgrund der flut von 2002 wird
sich das also gerade abgespielt hallo
aus dresden wir sind hier am dresdner
neumarkt quasi im herzen von triesen der
sächsischen landeshauptstadt
hier befindet sich direkt hinter mir auf
einem kleinen pavillon der die
tiefgarage führt eine sirene
die hat laut vorführeffekt leider nicht
funktioniert wir haben es aber aus
anderen teilen der stadt hier gehört
also ein kleines dumpfes summen es geht
zum teil immer noch und hier gibt es in
dresden eines wirklich der modernsten
sirenen systeme etwa 2,1 millionen euro
hat sich das die sächsische
landeshauptstadt kosten lassen nach der
flut 2002 wurden hier 240 sirenen
installiert und sozusagen flächendeckend
wird das stadtgebiet mit diesen sirenen
erreicht die nicht nur diese signal töne
von sich geben können sondern auch noch
sprechen durchsagen ermöglichen das
solle etwa in 20 minuten auch einmal
geprobt werden ich hoffe dann
funktioniert das auch hier am 9
wir hören es bei die im hintergrund
trotzdem noch immer ein bisschen wie
haben die menschen gerade reagiert als
es um 11 uhr los gängen es war ein
kurzes aufblicken aber die menschen sind
alle tief gefragt hast ich nehme an wir
haben es auch in der bild zeitung
gelesen dass heute es 11 uhr dieser
probe gibt und damit gab es hier keine
besonderen reaktionen
dann wollen wir einmal nach hamburg
schalten vielen dank erstmal nach
dresden und in hamburg gucken ob da alle
sirenen funktioniert haben wie lautet da
war mir zugeschaltet thomas knoop platz
aus hamburg wie haben die menschen
reagiert und vor allem haben alle
sirenen funktioniert ja ich stehe hier
am hamburger hafen wenn hinter mir für
seeschifffahrt und hydrographie auf dem
dach ist die sirene die hat um epo
funktioniert sogar gleich doppelt um 11
uhr und kurz danach noch einmal wollte
ich dann ausgelöst
die menschen im spiel geblieben haben
foto punkt einige haben ihre handys
gezückt und haben bei aufnahmen gemacht
insgesamt hat hamburg 131 ideen
überwiegend in den stadtteilen altona
mitte und bergedorf mit den vier und
marschlanden das hat den hintergrund
dass man die bevölkerung dort vor den
gefahren von sturmflut und hochwasser
waren möchte
und dieser zudem gibt es digitale
plakatwände auf den auch informationen
eingeblendet worden sind ihnen und auch
die bahn apps wurden ausgelöst haben in
hamburg hat alles funktioniert wie
sieht's in baden württemberg aus
stefanie käfer ist dort für uns
unterwegs sagt uns erst mal wo genau du
gerade die sirenen mit erlebt hast
kanäle ich stehe hier heute mit der
feuerwehr auf dem dach genauer gesagt
stehe ich auf dem feuerwehrgerätehaus
hier in bietigheim bissingen und es
besondere idee käme im vergleich zum
stuttgart ist dass stuttgart in den
90ern seiner ganzen serie von den
dächern geholt hat heute da jetzt nur
mit den mobilen sirenen auf dem
schlossplatz hauptbahnhof und
rotebühlplatz gewarnt wird hier in
bietigheim aber die fest installierte
sirenen sind eine davon hier bei der
feuerwehr auf dem dach
und unser feuerwehrkommandant kann uns
nachher auch noch genaueres dazu sagen
warum es gerade hier in der region in
bietigheim und den kleinen städten
drumrum anders abläuft als in stuttgart
direkt die erklärung wenn wir uns gleich
anhören von wollen wir aber in die
hauptstadt schreiten nach berlin zu kai
feldhaus kam er schon gehört dass man
hier eben nichts hört das heißt bei dir
ist relativ ruhig geblieben aber warum
ausgerechnet der hauptstadt keine
sirenen
ja ich allmählich muss zunächst mal
fragt ist schon vorbei hier ist davon
nichts angekommen um beantragt hier war
nicht zu hören um 11 uhr ganz normales
geschehen am brandenburger tor
der grund ist dass es schon gesagt die
sirenen sind die anfang der 90er jahre
abgebaut worden
der grund dafür ist mitnichten das dem
berliner eine serie mehr oder weniger
nicht weiter erschweren würde
der grund ist dass es kosten spart auf
der einen seite und auf der zweiten
seite möchte man den zentrale arbeiten
das heißt bei überflutungen stromausfall
oder großen bränden möchte man in den
savannen und das geht natürlich besser
mit war apps oder mit elektronische
werbetafeln die dann um umgenutzt werden
oder aber mit radiospot
da machen dann sie reden wie über die
gesamte stadt holen keinen sinn
bisher war aber auch sonst nicht so
wahnsinnig viel von irgendwelchen bahn
apps oder von warnungen hier am rande
war zu hören die fans wollen wir gleich
noch etwas mehr sprechen aber erstmal
vielen dank in berlin
von dort schauen wir nach düsseldorf
benjamin sack hat für uns dort zu gehört
und beobachtet wie dieser wahn tag lief
halo ist düsseldorf hinter mir heute
eine von 81 weiteren sie reden mit dem
eigentlichen proben laden los beim
ersten mal hat ein bisschen gedauert
jetzt hat sie pünktlich angefangen mit
ungefähr 120 dezibel
droht hier das signal raus und 20 30
meter entfernung ist das immer noch so
laut wie ein startendes flugzeug jetzt
app der bahn tun gerade wieder ein
bisschen ab in fünf minuten wird es dann
hier den dauerton wiedergeben
es sind elektronische sie reden die
haben die täler die man auf den dächern
von früher kannte abgelöst die geben
auch feedback welchen sirene ausgelöst
hat und welche eben nicht er wird dann
in zukunft geguckt woran es lag
aber ich bin zuversichtlich man hat hier
auch aus dem angrenzenden stadtgebieten
die töne gehört von den anderen sie
reden ich glaube das hat hier alles
wunderbar funktioniert also ein paar
verzögerung aber am ende hat jeder die
sirenen gehört in düsseldorf fielen dank
benjamin und zum schluss wollen wir auch
noch nach münchen schauen und hören ob
dort alles pünktlich liefern einem in
bayern um 11 uhr gab es darüber alarm
ja ich stehe hier im wunderschönen
garmisch partenkirchen vor der berühmten
skisprungschanze heute geht es aber
nicht um die skispringer sondern um
dieses gerät hier auf dem dach des
olympia hauses die sirene e 57 das ist
ein bayerischer ein gigantischer
urgestein von 1957 die sollte früher im
kalten krieg die bevölkerung vor allem
angriff der ostblockstaaten waren ja
aber soll ich sagen sie ist etwas
vermisst aber sie hat es immer noch
drauf
pünktlich um 11 gegen die sirene los und
sie war weit und breit zu hören mehr
nachrichten und break linie es nur weil
die schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergisst nichts abonnieren